foreign
and now from our 8 news now
investigators Harry Reid International
Airport is one of our country's busiest
that it is it's not just tourists coming
in but it's neighbors like us headed out
as well so when one family parked at the
airport they were shocked when they
landed and their car was gone 8 news now
investigator David charns with the
security flaw that he discovered David
yeah Brian Denise we went through dozens
of police reports finding well there are
cameras and security measures in place
they may not always be working
because Dad you're gonna have to pick me
up I mean there's no car here I'm like
you got to be kidding me Chris Aaron
sibia's family got quite the surprise
when they flew into Harry Reid airport
this summer he was dead there's no
vehicle there Aaron sibia says his wife
parked that car on the fourth floor of
the terminal one garage around four that
morning she was headed out on a flight
and took the key with her hours later
when Aaron sivia's son flew in to grab
the car it was gone and to come you know
to the airport and leave for a couple
days and come back and your vehicle's
missing it's terrible it's a terrible
feeling the eight news now investigators
found Aaron sibia's car is one of about
four dozen Vehicles stolen from airport
property that victims have reported to
Las Vegas Metro Police over the past two
years my concern is not the vehicle is
just at four o'clock in the morning
women men young
older people could go out there and
something could happen to them and
there's no
no camera to to see what's going on we
don't want to have any holes in our
security or any holes in the
surveillance that we have at the airport
here but
so are there holes not that I'm aware of
Captain Gregory Munson is in charge of
Metro's team here do you think people
are surprised that cars are getting
stolen from the airport
I I would say that you you would think
that because obviously you're in a
location that's secure right there are
cameras everywhere there's one right
above us actually
um so there are cameras everywhere that
are monitoring things but not always do
we catch everything on camera while
there are cameras in license plate
readers throughout airport garages the
a2l investigators found they don't
always work we went through dozens of
stolen vehicle reports finding
surveillance and systems in place are
not catching nor preventing all theft
one report writing the department of
Aviation did not have any surveillance
cameras at the location of occurrence
another airport staff did not have any
video surveillance of his vehicle
entering the parking garage or leaving
with more than 2 million cars parked
here last year Munson says the chance of
being a victim of a crime is Slim the
chances of a car getting out of this
airport without it being caught on
camera I would say is probably one in a
billion chances
um but could a camera go down could
something malfunction that that happens
right and then those things have to be
addressed He suggests taking your
parking with you and most importantly
your keys and if you see something say
something we do get a lot of calls but
we want even more the car could be
replaced has been replaced it's just a
human cannot be replaced Aaron sibia
bought a new car but he's not parking it
at the airport to this day he says the
parking office has no record of his car
going in or more importantly going out
but somehow it got there somehow it got
there somehow it left
and as the captain mentioned there
kartha from the airport is rare but as
we did show you it is happening in
addition to cameras in license plate
readers police and security officers are
walking through the garages to keep us
safe I'm David charns 8 News Now
David thank you police says sometimes
thieves take off the license plate of
the stolen car making them almost
impossible to find they say there are
plans to upgrade surveillance in the
garage